neuron thousands of people continue to
take to the streets to protest the u.s.
withdraw from the nuclear deal but they
were also targeting their own government
Elizabeth Palmer is in the Iranian
capital Tehran with the latest this
morning Elizabeth good morning good
morning president Trump's decision to
pull the u.s. out of the nuclear deal
has sent shockwaves rolling through this
whole region an amplified widespread
public anger after Friday prayers the
hardliners hit the streets
none of these regime loyalists would
dare say especially to an American
reporter but Iranians are furious with
their own government's failure to
deliver basics like electricity and
water and decent wages in January
grassroots protests spread like wildfire
and for the first time angry crowds
burned pictures of the previously
untouchable Supreme Leader President
Trump
pulling out of the nuclear deal and
Iran's missile exchanges with Israel are
just ramping up the pressure in a
country that's already dangerously close
to boiling point Iran says as far as its
concerned the nuclear deal is not yet
dead foreign minister Javad Zarif sets
off today on a tour of negotiations in
Russia China and Europe to see what can
be salvaged
Anthony Elizabeth Palmer in Tehran
thanks